it is the greatest irony of my life that  losing my husband helped me find deeper  gratitude gratitude for the kindness of  my friends the love of my family and the  laughter of my children my hope for you  is that you can find that gratitude not  just on the easy days like today but on  the hard days when you will need it  Dave's death changed me in very profound  ways I learned about the depths of  sadness and the brutality of loss but I  also learned that when life sucks you  under you can kick against the bottom  find the surface and breathe again I'm  sharing this with you today in the hopes  that on this day in your lives with all  the momentum and the joy you can learn  in life the lessons I only learned in  death lessons about hope about strength  and about the light within us that will  not be extinguished